[Music]
some are calling it a home run bringing
the Oakland A's and a new baseball
stadium to Las Vegas now before that
becomes a reality there's a tight
deadline to get half a billion dollars
for it and a local union is also left
wondering if the people working there
will be able to unionize eight news now
reporter Ryan Matthey joins us live near
the land intended to house that Stadium
which is near Tropicana and Dean Martin
Ryan
Denise Bryant this entire Project's
estimated at 1.5 billion dollars all on
just over 49 acres of land you can see
some of it right behind me here but
legislations are asking or excuse me the
A's are asking for a third of that price
tag from Public Funding legislators are
questioning when they're going to ask
the legislators for that while union
leaders say the teams need to step up to
the plate
none of this is simple none of it is
easy Jeremy Aguero is principal analyst
for Applied analysis The Firm hired to
help the A's craft a deal this
transaction is in many ways less
complicated than others that we've
worked through before and he comes with
experience
he also helped to bring a legion stadium
and the finances for it much of the
groundwork then he says is making a
potential Bill easier to craft but this
one is different and that it attempts to
capture all of the taxes created by the
stadium and reinvest them back into the
stadium that does not exist in the state
of Nevada today and so it would require
the legislature to do that a special tax
District to get up to 500 million
dollars but State Assembly speaker Steve
Yeager told the Nevada independent on
Wednesday a bill to create this has not
yet been presented and the clock's
ticking The Proposal needs to be
submitted before the current legislative
session ends on June 5th I don't want to
suggest you that time is infinite but I
also believe that as those conversations
continue and as deal points get refined
that that legislation can come together
in a reasonable way end of the day these
are part-time jobs and while the
legislature Waits on that The Culinary
Union which represents 60 thousand and
Resort and Stadium workers in Nevada
says the A's won't confirm if the
workers there will be able to unionize
secretary treasurer Ted Papa George says
they've been in Communications for over
a year the governor needs to understand
that too and does the legislature
uh because otherwise the voters will
have their final say
now there is the possibility this goes
past the legislative session the
governor in that scenario would need to
call a special session to tackle all
this for context Allegiant Stadium just
down the way went through this entire
process in 2016. their special session
took just four days reporting live near
Dean Martin and Tropicana right mathie
eight news now